林黛玉和雪宝猜的交往在月毒反馈过程中没没引发争议。这种争议里往往参入时代背景改变带来的思想偏见。我们就以第42回《恒无君篮言解疑屁为例》管馈一二。
事件的起因是刘老龙进大官员,众人玩九令游戏,是所谓金冤养三宣崖排令。在这场游戏里,林黛玉后胜心发作一时忘情,就把母单停西香寄里的细文说了两句出来。
元阳又到,左边一个天,带玉到梁晨梅景内河天。保柴听了回头看着她,带玉只顾怕罚也不理论。
元阳到,中间紧平颜色敲,带玉到,沙窗也没有红娘抱。元阳到,剩了二六八点奇,带玉到双沾玉座影朝宜。元阳到,臭成蓝子好彩花,带玉到,仙仗相调少咬花。
林黛玉说完梁晨梅景内河天,削薄拆回头看了她一眼没有说话。
第四十二回,横无君蓝言解一屁。削薄拆的这一眼,终于有了解释。她将带玉单独叫来,劝告她以后少独砸书以免乱了性情。
削薄拆的做法,被部分独者视为狗拿号子多管闲事。另有独者指出,削薄拆有何脸面批评带玉。
你自己若没读过这些杂书,如何知道梁晨梅景内河天,沙窗也没有红娘报,这些竞书辞聚。
保拆劝告带玉,起不是以五十步孝百步。
布红君以为,朱君可用小人之心独精平梅,却不能以小人之心独红楼梦。
曹雪卿给薛薄拆的这次劝说,起名为,横无君蓝言解一屁。
将薛薄拆之与定平为蓝言,作者态度如何不表可知。
那么,林带玉面对薛薄拆的劝说,她本人是什么态度呢?我们来看原住的描述。
带玉一响,方想起琢石与剪点,那母单庭西香寄说了两句,
布纯红的脸,便上来楼着宝拆孝道,好姐姐,原是我不知道随口说的,你交给我再不说了。
宝拆孝道,我也不知道,听你说的怪生的,所以请教你。
带玉道,好姐姐,你别说与别人,我以后再不说了。
面对宝拆的寻问,带玉的第一反应是布纯红的脸,随后上来楼着宝拆就开始求饶。
对于经知读者来说,母单庭西香寄是优秀国学作品,可放在红楼梦的时代背景,这类书是古惑人性的竞书,尤其为世家大祖所排斥。
盖阴这些财子家人小说,无理性逻辑可寻。古代男女之房借线一场严格,好门贵族小姐李英受到更加严克的管述。
可在财子家人小说里,小姐和外男非常轻松就见到了,而且一见钟情,随后就开始翻墙月后的展开所谓的爱情。
另一方面,这种竞书虽无逻辑,但却能激发少男少女对青春爱恋的向往,包括我们今天意识如此。
许多脱离现实的偶像爱情剧,非常受轻少年的欢迎,并由此产生对恋爱的向往。
越读这种书籍,很容易让处于青春期的少男少女春心荡样,天天幻想着跟笑话笑草谈恋爱,虽不拆所说的乱了性情正是此意。
而在封建时代,这种苗头直接威胁到父母之命没所知言的婚姻模式,故而是被严格禁止的。
当然,用今天的价值观来看保采的券说,显得十分封建落物。
这也是今天许多学者责备削保拆的重要佐证。
可大家却忽略了一点,那就是削保拆的观点是红楼书中所有人的共识,包括林代玉自己也认同保采的说法。
坐着曹雪琴将削保采的券尾之语定评为蓝眼,另有批数人指验摘,第22回保采将机之年生日,
习上保采点了一出,鲁志深最闹舞台山,指验摘就拆代二人性情频道。
世纪,保采可未不学以,不似代域只以母单庭,便心神不自主义,真有学问如此,保采事业。
当然,直验摘的这种观点放在今天以然不是用了,他以封建传统李教对女性的束缚,作为判断人品道德的标准。
这种判断标准是落后的,但我们同时必须承认。
这种落后的封建李教,被曹雪琴,指验摘,以及书中的削保采铃代域认定为金颗预律。
从削保采个人视角来看,他的做法和呼君子知道,并非某些小人之心的独者所平汗的一五十步孝百步。
铃代域在艳会上言语有失,削保采如果真的要针对铃代域,最好的办法是当场点破,让家母王府认等当场注意到铃代域的错误。
可削保采只是一笑,并没有这么做。
齐二,削保采券节铃代域乃是单独教来,实施蓝言解疑庇时,避开重人,分明是给代域留机会,
其神问代域是假,包庇代域反财是真。
齐三,削保采自己也读过进书,所以他才知道领代域犯了错,当他点破代域的过错后,居然毫不顾忻自己的名声,坦然说出当年的经历。
原住记,保采道,你当我是谁,我也是个逃棄的,从小七八岁上也够个人缠的,
我们家也算是个读书人家,祖父手里也爱藏书,先是人口多,子妹弟兄都在一处,都怕看正景书,弟兄们也有爱诗的,也有爱词的。
诸如这些西香,皮怕,以及原人白种无所不有,他们是偷背着我们看,我们却也偷背着他们看,后来大人知道了,打的打骂的骂,烧的烧才丢开了。
所以咱们女儿家不认得自得到好,男人们读书不明理,上解不如不读书的好,何况你我。
一习话,说的待遇垂头吃茶,心下暗服,只有答应试的一字。
虚保拆完全可以隐隐藏着些信息,从而居高凌晒批评待遇,可她却讲出自己西年看近书的经历,无疑自降台阶,以平等地位来和待遇探讨,如此谈当的行为让待遇都心下暗服。
待遇是个极其聪明的人,所以到了第四十五回,金兰气互抛金兰语,临待遇和虚保拆彼此轻素,待遇再次提起之前的事,并且告诉保拆。
若是保拆说了那些,竟输辞聚,自己一定不会这么轻易饶过她,可保拆却没有这么对待她。
这也是凌待遇最珍贵的地方,不宏君个人以为,相比保拆的体贴,此处待遇的反思更加珍贵。
这足以证明凌待遇绝不是个嚼劲的女子,她没有利用凌芽历尺去无理角三分,而是真心反思自己,从而和保拆冰是前嫌,促成了金兰气。
细品凌待遇虚保拆的交往,人物内心转变细腻入微,不需要刻意进行情节推进。
这种协法细品经为天人,粗独者却未同交辣,不懂红楼有何可汗之处,可见人责书,书也责任。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。